we have major breaking news on several
fronts tonight President Trump is not
the target of the investigation of
longtime personal attorney Michael Cohen
we're learning tonight the president has
received that assurance from the Deputy
Attorney General and the Trump legal
team has grown by one former New York
Mayor Rudy Giuliani is now on board
let's get the latest from chief White
House correspondent John Roberts
traveling with the president in West
Palm Beach Florida good evening John
breca diva to use and fast-moving
developments this afternoon first
sources close to the investigation tell
FOX News Dan last week in an oval office
meeting with the number of principals
including the president Rod Rosenstein
the Deputy Attorney General told the
president that he is not a target of the
Michael Cohen investigation that Cowan
is the only target of that investigation
you'll remember a week ago Monday
Cohen's office is home in his hotel
wormer rated at the FBI coming in and
taking virtually everything that was in
there and in subsequent court documents
we find out that Cohen had three clients
the major one of which was the president
but rod Rosenstein telling the president
he is not a target which raises a
question if how does he know that before
it to be a fact if prosecutors have not
had an opportunity to look at the
materials that were seized in Cohen's
home because they have been tied up in
litigation the President and Cohen
wanting to have a Special Master look at
those documents to find out which ones
are subject to attorney-client privilege
and then there is the revelation this
afternoon that Rudy Giuliani is joining
the team in a statement the president
saying Rudy is great he has been my
friend for a long time and wants to get
this matter quickly resolved for the
good of the country and back just a
second again to the assurance from rod
Rosen Stein that the president was not a
target of the Comey inves the Cohen
investigation should information arise
where the president does become a target
of that investigation that could be
problematic for the investigation
because here you have the Deputy
Attorney General saying he's not a
target and then subtly he becomes a
target and again there was some very
prominent people in that room all of
this on what was yet another busy day
for the White House to begin
with a trip to the Florida Keys
President Trump had border security on
his mind today jetting off to Key West
this morning ground zero in the East
Coast battle against drugs and human
trafficking talking about drugs and
stopping these drugs and other things
human trafficking some of the other
forms of trafficking President Trump
also had his sights trained on America's
West Coast with some choice words for
California's governor who agreed to
stand National Guard troops to the
border but not to assist in the
immigration control President Trump
tweeting Governor Jerry Brown announced
he will deploy up to 400 National Guard
troops to do nothing the crime rate in
California is high enough and the
federal government will not be paying
for Governor Brown charade
we need border security and action not
words and the president praising San
Diego County for joining the federal
lawsuit against sanctuary cities
tweeting today california's dangerous
policies released violent criminals back
into our communities putting all
Americans at risk
president Trump hopes to address another
critical security issue North Korea's
nuclear program in a planned summit with
Kim jong-un in a news conference with
japan's Prime Minister the president
said he's prepared to walk if Kim isn't
serious about denuclearization if I
think that it's a meeting that is not
going to be fruitful we're not going to
go if the meeting when I'm there is not
fruitful I will respectfully leave the
meeting today another positive sign
South Korea announcing that Kim has
dropped his demands that US troops
vacate the Korean Peninsula as a
condition for dismantling his nuclear
program and the White House continues to
work on a location for the meeting Fox
News is told that among the possible
sites are Singapore Sweden and
Switzerland less likely but still under
consideration is Vietnam as president
Trump works at a North Korean break
through relations with Russia took
another hit Russia today demanding
compensation for tariffs on steel and
aluminum Russia claims the tariffs are
safeguard measures designed to protect
US companies and
as president Trump has claimed a matter
of national security and despite a
Sunday claim by ambassador nikki Haley
that more sanctions against Russia were
imminent president Trump said at
mar-a-lago nothing is planned that was
at least not right now well do sanctions
as soon as they very much deserve it we
will have that is a question there has
been nobody tougher on Russia than
President Donald Trump the president was
asked about it yesterday but did not
respond on what was responsible for the
disconnect between what he was thinking
about Russian sanctions and what the
United Nations ambassador said on Sunday
morning but the White House felt
compelled on Sunday to put in a call to
the Russian ambassador in Washington DC
and say we're not planning any sanctions
at least not right now
Brett well in that a bit later John
Roberts in West Palm Beach John thanks